RUI COSTA: Jonathan, it
looks like you're getting
ready for the World Cup.
JONATHAN KOLA: I am actually
training for the next one--
2022.
Watch out.
RUI COSTA: A little early, no?
JONATHAN KOLA: Well,
you know, I have
to stay ready so that I
don't have to get ready.
RUI COSTA: Fair.
Fair.
My name's Rui Costa.
Welcome to another
episode of "Take 5."
This is Jonathan.
You want to introduce yourself?
JONATHAN KOLA: Hi, my
name is Jonathan Kola.
I'm a Customer Engineer
here at Google.
RUI COSTA: Awesome.
What are we demoing
today, Jonathan?
JONATHAN KOLA:
Today, we're going
to walk through Multi-cluster
Ingress with Google Kubernetes
Engine.
RUI COSTA: Very cool.
Let's get started?
JONATHAN KOLA: Yep, let's do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
On GCP, the nodes on
your Kubernetes cluster
could either all be in one
zone, or across multiple zones
in a region.
And on these nodes, you could be
running multiple services which
you need to expose to the
outside world somehow.
And for this, you would
use an Ingress resource.
And on GCP, we implement that
using the Google Cloud Load
Balancer.
It allows you to map HTTP
requests or particular service
or services running
on your nodes.
Now, with Multi-cluster Ingress,
it is actually a new feature.
It allows you to
route your traffic
across multiple services
across multiple nodes.
So it's a really powerful
feature, a really cool feature.
So let's jump into the demo.
I'm in my console
now, and specifically
in the Google Kubernetes
Engine section.
And you can see, I have two
clusters here that I've already
provisioned, cluster
1 and cluster 2,
running in US East
4 and Europe West 1.
Diving into one of the clusters,
we can take a quick look
at the configuration.
It is a basic default
setup, so three nodes
running Kubernetes 1.9.7.
These are essentially the
defaults, so nothing too fancy
going on here.
We can also take a
look at the workloads
that run on the cluster.
And we see we have
two workloads.
These are two
deployments running
on the two different clusters.
And they are both
called Zone Printer.
If we dive into one of
the applications, one
of the deployments, we can take
a look at what the UI shows us.
It shows us basic
metrics, but what's
going on with those
workloads running
on the cluster, or one
particular cluster,
in this case.
And we can see by
setup that it's just
comprised of three
different parts,
all serving the
same application.
Now, we've also actually
provisioned an Ingress resource
beforehand, which
we'll take a look at.
And if you remember, an
Ingress resource on Google
is provisioned using
the Google Cloud Load
Balancer, which is what
we're going to navigate to.
And if we dive into our
Google Cloud Load Balancer
implementation, we can
actually grab the IP address
that's going to be
our [INAUDIBLE] IP
address that we'll
actually use to communicate
with the services.
So we can grab that IP
address and go to our browser
and redirect ourselves
to that address.
And this is what
we're greeted with.
We have the US flag and
a nice welcome message
from Ashburn, Virginia.
That is the exact place
where our cluster is running.
It's in the US East 4 A zone.
Now, what we want to
do next is simulate
what would happen if
one of our clusters,
or the applications running
on those clusters, falls over.
Underneath the
hood, GKE clusters
are actually Managed
Instance groups.
So we can navigate to the
Managed Instance group page
and actually simulate
what this kind of scenario
would look like.
So if we set Restart
Event to actually restart
all of the nodes, this will
kill what's running right now.
The nodes will be drained.
And that cluster, for a brief
period, will be unavailable.
So we've done that.
Hopefully, in a few seconds,
we will have our cluster coming
offline, but soon
to be restarted.
So let's navigate
back to the browser
and see what
actually happens now.
And after a few
seconds, success.
We've been redirected
to the Belgium zone.
That's Europe West 1, where
our second cluster is running
with the same application.
So this is pretty cool.
In a normal scenario,
wherever your users
are trying to access
the application from,
they would actually be
routed to the zone that's
closest to them.
This is a powerful
Multi-cluster Ingress.
So what do you think, Rui?
RUI COSTA: That was
amazing, Jonathan.
Thank you.
JONATHAN KOLA: Thank you.
RUI COSTA: Thanks,
everyone, for watching.
Remember to click the
Subscribe and Share Video.
JONATHAN KOLA: And if you are
working on any cool projects
and you want to connect
with us, click on the link
in the description below.
RUI COSTA: Thanks, everyone.
JONATHAN KOLA: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]